what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch from
new rock stars today when King the exact
moment when King when King killed Thanos
yeah we're gonna react to this today hey
John how are you how are you I'm good
how are you sir
um I want to know how you're doing
beforehand I'm doing good you can hear
it in my voice
I've been just excited to keep listening
to this baritone of yours see now it's
just stuffy alrighty John just shot a
reaction Dumb and Dumber keep looking
for that oh teasing for the future what
you don't need to talk about my biceps
John but you can't talk about my new
t-shirt John please plug in the shirt
the shirt who influences the influencers
Rorschach inspired in one of my personal
faves it's my Twitter bio
and now it's a shirt
they finally succeeded come full circle
your Twitter bio is legit yeah screw
influencers am I right screw them all
all of them who influences them it's a
shopster edition.com go go get it yeah
real rejects leave a like all right
and quantumania will open Marvel phase
five with Kang the Conqueror as the vast
Cult of Warring Champions that the
Avengers have to face but given Ken's
champ status does it logically follow
that he must have killed Thanos at some
point or at many points Jurassic crew
are now specifically pitting Thanos
versus gang and when you go back to
re-watch Loki and Multiverse of Madness
Infinity war end game you can actually
pinpoint these specific Nexus moment
when Kang would have targeted the Mad
Titan and I'm gonna break down oh
interestingly assassination tells us
about the surprising status of the 616
universe as we know it you know if they
have just one line in there about you
know if they talk about Thanos if
ant-man's like gloating about how they
you know him in the Avengers they they
took on Thanos and then he just has some
throwaway line about like oh yeah I've
killed a bunches I've killed 20 Thanos
like 20 to 30 Thanos I have a necklace
of Thanos ears
little chambers that would just make him
seem so badass and be an ultimate
ultimate there it's a quick way to
communicate to the audience that he is a
worse threat than that just do a cutaway
where it's just like that episode of The
Walking Dead with Glenn and Negan just
do that
there's a montage
you know me bashing his head in yeah
yeah it's cut to that joke was not clear
that joke could have been clear it could
have been clear in an interview at
Brazilian Comic-Con earlier this month
Quantum Main IA director Peyton Reed
unprovoked compared Kang to Thanos we're
uh encountering an antagonist who's
unlike anything they've ever experienced
and that includes Thanos and notice
right at the end of that line Peyton
Reed fist bumps Kang actor Jonathan
majors
in this interview but was later asked
about his workout regimen and how
physical he would be getting as Kang and
we want to know if you're going to use
any of these workouts you had to do with
your bite on this next movie all of it
all of it all of it like Hulk no I'm
kidding it's funny because if you read
Dynasty Kank he doesn't fight it's not
like a brawl guy yeah is that going to
happen here you're going to get all of
it get all of it that's cool that's cool
King's gonna do backflips that's right
confirmed push-ups he's gonna do
one-handed push-ups with his pinkies
yeah I can travel through time but have
you seen me travel through the air oh
able to leave tall buildings at a single
bound wow that's right man he's gonna
jump on a skateboard it's gonna be crazy
all gangs every iteration you're gonna
get all of it I clearly want to be here
and I'm not just doing this so I won't
get fined I don't know maybe Major's
just had trouble hearing the
interviewers it was really loud in that
room but he is or he's racist as
discussed in other interviews the wide
range of characterizations he would get
to create SK as the primary thing that
Drew him to this role and while Peyton
Reed has described this quantumania Kang
as a variant who conserves of energy
with Majors saying all of it and his
fist bump with the director the mention
of him being more fearsome than Thanos I
think Majors is gonna play at least one
Kang who makes Thanos say just that for
a drop of blood oh [ __ ] remember in the
quantumania trailer for the show we've
seen so far Ken has implied he has
killed countless Avengers in the past
and we know for sure ever seen someone
read so much into a fist bump I know oh
it says everything which Thanos was a
major antagonist and Anna showed up in
Loki episode two in the multiple choice
question on Miss minutes training module
Thanos has two apples he eats both the
realizes he wants more he goes back in
time 20 minutes and eats the apples
again does this mean the apples will not
have existed in the timeline he left hey
no because time is constantly happening
B the question doesn't matter because
the branch cannot change another
dedication to the voice would have been
hungry prior because the grandfather
Paradox already accounted for the change
of matter before it's moved when we look
back at this the TVA Rank and files seem
to suggest B was a correct answer but I
don't know by the Loki season one finale
we go see your answer seems actually
look whatever your thoughts on this
anyone who thinks that they firmly
understand 100 the logic of Loki season
one and what exactly happened in that
finale they don't even understand it
which is why I am actually revisiting it
currently for a major project that I am
working on announcement
or about this Kang period he remains is
that he made an exception for The
Avengers to use time travel he remains
wanted the 616 Avengers to defeat Thanos
using the Time Heist when Slayer
confirmed this to Loki in episode one
we're not here to talk about the
Avengers oh no no what they did was
supposed to happen you you escaping was
not now I have theorized before that he
remains made that exception so that Tony
Stark would later unlock Quantum time
travel with that inverted Mobius strip
in his basement this being the discovery
that Nathan Richards would later build
on and master a thousand years later and
that he who remained scripted this out
so that Stark would die shortly after so
that he would have no time to dismantle
that technology or you know bird in the
ocean like he likes to do with this town
I really hope they confirmed that MCU
the more it starts to seem like it's
less of a sacred timeline but really an
exception to the multiversal norm 616 is
like a rogue timeline it's a variant
branch that went unprooned the normal
Marvel universe is probably supposed to
have mutants alongside Avengers right
but surely to prune all other Kang
Rivals during that multiversal war that
he talked about in the finale he left
one 616 timeline untouched so that it
would keep his own origin intact
basically a massive Kang tree he remains
clipped all other branches so other
carrying apples fell down to the ground
then only one branch remaining that left
to the heat remains [ __ ] too high
enough off the ground so hungry hungry
Thanos could need that Apple that kind
of makes metaphors there but I hope it
made sense but as a better example okay
[Laughter]
first had no Tony Stark present
currently but it was still a universe
where he once existed based on those
Ultron sentries yes with an Illuminati
formed by Stephen Strange who had led
them to defeat Thanos in their Infinity
War how by dream walking with the dark
holes now we don't often discuss the
past possession of the dark holes and
who handed it off to whom something I
suspect that we will learn more about in
Phase 5 with titles like Agatha the
coven of chaos but I think The a38
Illuminati's win over Thanos was
scripted for them by Kang Kang had
curated their timeline so that a38
strange would use the dark hole to
defeat Thanos now why do we think Kang
was involved with this I mean I thought
King was involved with all of it yeah I
thought he wrote Every timeline so just
every timeline must have a Thanos
portion but everyone's plot line is has
been scripted by King isn't that what
Loki was establishing Beyond Thanos
introduce with every video every
character yeah it has to be every single
character this is like every single
character right if you weren't in the
script Ant-Man that's why he's not
killed you yeah and killed the
Quicksilver yeah I feel like you can do
that with any character killed everyone
am I missing something no I I I think
you're right I don't know he seems to be
in control of everyone's fate and if you
step out of line they're gonna come find
you so I'm not like dogging on your
video or anything like that wait what is
the I thought there was going to be
something a little bit let's find out
maybe he'll maybe I'll have an answer
well two major clues in this crime scene
first the Gauntlet that Ted Thanos has
acquired 4 out of six Infinity Stones
he's got the power the space reality and
the Soul stones but not the Mind Stone
and not the time Stone so this Thanos
must have been killed right before he
would have acquired the time Stone
secondly it's the way this Thanos was
clearly killed his own sword plunged
into his chest now we don't know which
of these Illuminati had delivered the
death blow but given the fact that this
is a corporeal wound and not like him
blasted to Smithereens by Blackpool or
something I'm going to assume that this
was some kind of combo three Richard
slingshoting that sword using his
elastic body
I think that because reads elastic
slingshot Maneuvers are really the one
physical Edge he has over his opponents
it's one range attack that Thanos
wouldn't have seen coming with that
mailbox is a death blow that needed
Kang's patriarchal ancestor to be in the
mix that's why I think Multiverse of
Madness made sure to include that line
about Reed Richards having children Reed
Richards is a distant ancestor to
Nathaniel Richards Kane so in the a38
universe Kang did this so that these
Marvel heroes would have no name to have
to invent time travel to undo famous ah
you were gay yeah okay this is the one
time travel timeline yeah same art our
timeline yeah 616. I call that our
timeline that's where we live
in here that's right but yeah the main
one that we follow is the only one that
was allowed to have time travel maybe
what I think Mr Voss is alluding to
there had to be a special kind of
variation perhaps for every way that
Thanos died like he doesn't die the
exact same way every one of them sure
you know yeah and so this one variation
had to leave the necessity for time
travel and the rest of them just had to
be like ah here's a Nifty you know way
to do this so that uh yeah they can stay
contained to your own little timeline or
people are yelling at us in the comments
right now why don't you there's fake
fans he's limited these Heroes to
multiversal travel by dreamwalking from
the dark old sorcery not technological
Quantum time travel that Kang would use
in the future they use magic not science
so that Kang and only magic is science
waiting to be discovered whatever sloppy
incursions their magic caused so this
right here at this moment that Kang
engineered thanos's death right before
the time Stone would enter the play and
snuffing out a future in-game Time Heist
which makes sense because this battle of
Titan was conqueror Thanos at his most
vulnerable and likely was a Nexus moment
for Thanos to be assassinated in any
timeline that's why it makes sense to
blame Peter Quill for punching Thanos
out of his trance in Infinity War as one
moment The Avengers could have taken
Thanos down before the snap happened
we're right
and it needed to be part of this overall
dog pile because when you re-watch
infinity War he totally provided
essential distractions for other
Avengers to be able to pin Thanos but
really they were so close to ending the
616 Infinity War all that Kang would
have had to do to change the odds here
would be to add someone like oh I don't
know Ant-Man Ant-Man could have snuck
inside the gauntlet and wriggled it off
the hand he could have got it or the bum
hole the bum give him a heart attack he
could blown his butt out any number of
hypothetical what ifsc right and for
Kang to be a true conqueror Thanos must
just be a villain from an older age that
merely played a part in Kang's
machinations and died at a deliberate
moment of Kang's choosing for most
realities that moment was definitely on
Titan except in 616 when Kang needed
Thanos to get far enough for the
Avengers to start putting the word
Quantum in front of everything I get it
okay so every timeline he's supposed to
die on Titan yes and it would have
happened on our timeline again ours we
own 616. it would have happened on our
timeline if Peter Quill hadn't gone to
mess things up damn Earth dweller quill
that's why yeah okay got it yeah it's
all his fault but he was saying that he
he allowed that to happen Kang so that
way Tony could create that'll yeah
that's okay right so
Peter needed to do that that's right
yeah Kevin wrote a weird detail where
he's like Peter's gonna help help
distract Thanos so the Defenders can get
the drop but then he's also going to
break him out of the trance so then the
time travel will have to be a quantity
oh that is a fascinating Theory and that
also saves you from the weirdness of the
writing of Peter doing no that's
actually a really cool theory yes
we were finally understood what we were
watching at the very end of the video it
is actually a really cool Theory welcome
to a real reaction to this yes yeah yeah
this is Grime to new Rockstar subscribe
to real rejects leave a like pick
yourself up who influences the
influencers how can you call us
influencers who do you think we're
influencing at this moment yeah you to
get a shirt let's send this to them
Chris wamov Chris is known as one of the
nicest guys at our patreon page but I'd
like to think that if I was traveling
the Multiverse you'd find out that only
on our Earth is he a nice guy that every
other Earth he is some kind of Destroyer
real just a nihilistic son of a beast
going around ruining people's I'm not
saying he's like a violent you know
shopraved evil person he's not like you
know the newest people or something but
he's just very frustrating to be around
you know like he is human talks about
himself he never has to any questions
very dramatic like he's very drawn just
Petty
when someone's opening up about
themselves make it about himself
energy vampire noise fortunately on our
Earth
on to back to the Earth our Earth 616.
It Was Written in the Kang script I was
listening you can't blame me because
it's part of improv that's right and you
can and then Kang wrote the John listen
I'm saying that on our Earth we got the
good one I forgot what I was going I got
so distracted this is the best Chris I
hope you have a Happy New Year
[Music]